I go so much here on behalf of on
gamescom we're going to give you a
rundown of this year's international
event now to start off we're here in the
Western Bellevue hotel we have teams
from all around the world attending here
we ever talked about 19 teams and that
have made it to this stage of the
international from those 1911 on receive
direct invites basically the best teams
in the world received a direct invite
for the post and guarantee dyslexia the
remaining slots were taken up through
four regional qualifiers now from those
qualifiers for teams received an invite
directly to here and then the four
runners-up those four teens were
fighting for their last chance to get to
the event and one of them was victorious
which was North Americans team liquid
now moving into next stage of playoffs
it was over five days we're talking
about minimum of 140 games maybe even
more it's been a very long exhausting
week and as you can see the players are
having fun behind there they're still
chilling out here in the practice area
but focusing on those results we see 16
teams in total with after the playoffs
basically eight were eliminated moving
on to the main event which is going to
be in Seattle's key arena the basketball
stadium we're looking at maybe over
10,000 people attending they're all from
across the world to see these teams
fight out for a total 10.8 million
dollars it actually started off at one
point six and in in the space of a
couple months the greens is basically
porter compendium which has helped boost
the prize pool here which also means
that first-place prize is now 5 million
dollars with the 18 to 10 in there a
minimum prize of half a million dollars
we have five Chinese teams at the main
event to European and one American in
terms of upsets we saw the 2013
champions alliance knocked out of the
tournament they will not be attending
the main event in the akira net seattle
including those is also your big
international veterans like fanatic and
mouse sports they also struggle to get
through the groups and it's we've had
some huge upsets a basically but folks
on the main event that kicks off on the
18th of july so later this week basis it
so you should definitely check it out if
you're not a you know if you're not a
daughter to player if you've never
watched order to there is a nupe stream
it basically teaches you how to play the
game whilst the games are going on it's
pretty crazy they're pulling out all the
stops this year a valve and it's been
amazing been so far you should
definitely check out the main event
which as I said 18 for july for more
coverage you can find this a non gamers
com or you can check out the dollar to
international page which is dot 2.com /
international thanks guys